the argentine president alberto
fernandez
swearing in his new health minister
carlo visotti
keen to put behind him a scandal over
his government's handling
of the kovid 19 pandemic
just a few days ago the now disgraced
former health minister genius gonzalez
garcia
was welcoming the arrival in argentina
of this batch of more than half a
million doses
of the oxford astra seneca vaccine
with the vaccine agreement we have
reached and the actions we are taking we
estimate that in august or september we
will have vaccinated all argentines who
are in a position to be vaccinated
many health professionals questioned his
optimism concerned that not enough doses
are arriving quickly enough
the vaccines aren't arriving we can't
produce what's not available
unless we now know you're friends with
people in the right places
this prominent argentine journalist on
public radio
explained how his friend the now former
health minister
insisted he jumped the cue to get
vaccinated
other cases of senior politicians and
business leaders
and their families immediately came to
light the president
insisted that gonzales resign the rest
in the country where the virus has
killed more than 50 000 people and 2
million have been infected
must simply wait their turn
i have been waiting for it i really
couldn't wait because i have been locked
up for a year now
this program to vaccinate elderly people
in buenos aires province
began as the scandal came to light a
similar case is being investigated in
peru
where nearly 500 people among them a
former president and two ministers were
vaccinated weeks before the programme
for the rest of the population had even
begun
this in a country where covered 19 has
killed 45 000 people
and oxygen supplies are running
dangerously low
the governments of peru and here in
argentina now have the task of
rebuilding public faith in their
handling
of the coronavirus pandemic phrases like
we're all in this together and we're
doing all we can
ring hollow while people are being urged
to wait patiently in line to be
vaccinated
and the virus still kills daniel schwein
al jazeera buenos aires